[Applaudissements]
alors il est montée des
eaux est magnifique je suis très très
heureux de le rencontrer parce que tu
portes un peu on aurait aimé tes mais tu
es magnifique ah oui pourquoi il est
incroyable
tu de moi t'as vu ta gueule
moi
je dis alors fait une gaffe où il posait
des questions c'est incroyable je suis
très content de le voir il est je répond
par oui ou par non à ça oui voilà tu
vois ce que les sportifs à la ba oui ça
je suis sportif oui voilà bombardé mon
indice numéro un voilà
votre métier haut niveau
oui
vraiment il a fait un truc que vous avez
fait les géo est ce que vous avez fait j
j'ai pas fait les jeunes on est ce que
vous avez battu un record récemment
j'ai battu un record on peut dire ça
comme ça parce que c'est dans l'eau
c'est dans l'eau à daloa mal à dissocier
dans le
sas et de la cnps et non pas de l'opt et
est ce que rend bien vite ces herbes à
la vitesse de la vitesse dans la
traversée
oui une
traversée et la terreur ça avec nos
surfeurs nonchalant à surfer non ce que
vous avez un rapport avec la moussaka
spécialement comme ça je vous ai
dit ça va vraiment pas besoin est
oui mais est-ce que vous avez des
parents célèbres voilà j'ai des parents
célèbres est
ce que vous dites moi si fausses idées
au niveau nom n'est pas un des fils
caché de castel dit non
non donc est-ce que vos parents sont
acteurs non ils sont bons acteurs mais
ces maisons est ce que votre mère est
une femme politique oui ma mère est une
femme politique c'est non
donc si on dit votre nom là tout le
monde le connaît la france entière
de ma politique un peu politique chez
nous c'est le fils d'anne hidalgo
pourquoi politique à pascal et la baule
sous l'os
lui regarde droit dans les yeux ça va
être produit en duo droit dans les yeux
alors est ce que vous êtes le fils
d'anne hidalgo oui je suis
[Applaudissements]
germaneau le fils d'anne hidalgo ça se
soit bien parce qu'il a fait un exploit
extraordinaire
merci à turenne amis
je ne définissait comme nageur est
aventurier il a réussi sa descente des 7
184 km de la scène depuis sa source en
accostant sur la plage du havre en
juillet 2021 on a la vidéo de son
arrivée c'est un exploit extraordinaire
il n'a pas fait ça pour rien il a fait
ça pour sensibiliser la population à la
cause environnementale aux enjeux
écologiques actuels on va voir une bande
annonce du documentaire de sa traversée
c'est complètement fou ça fait et vous
la prochaine fois ils m'aident à fermer
[Musique]
certains athlètes de haut niveau
décident parfois de dépasser leurs
limites pour réaliser des exploits
extraordinaires
[Musique]
son arrivée regardez l'arrivée d'artur
leurs mains regarde
arthur germain vient d'arriver à paris
le fils d'anne hidalgo s'est lancé le
défi de descendre la seine à la nage le
but sensibiliser le grand public à la
pollution du fleuve en effectuant des
prélèvements le jeune nageur on a déjà
effectué près de 1200 ces prélèvements
pourraient peser dans le projet de
rendre la scène accessible aux nageurs
d'ici 2025 voulu par la maire de paris
la capitale n'est qu'une étape en tout
ce sont 7 184 km à parcourir en 52 jours
340 communes et 13 préfecture à travers
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous avez voulu traverser la
seine arche post il y avait trop
d'embouteillages
[Applaudissements]
et
tueur vraiment un service incroyable et
je voulais te dire on c'est vrai que ce
soir on reçoit arthur en ondes le fils
d'anne hidalgo le psy vous le dire ou le
taquine beaucoup anne hidalgo on espère
qu'on la recevra bientôt d'ailleurs et
voilà et c'est vrai qu'on taquine
beaucoup charlie mais vraiment ce qu'il
fait
c'est là le but emmanuel oui bravo mais
comment vous est venue l'idée sa part de
quoi belle idée ça a pris vraiment
beaucoup de temps à penser le projet en
fait c'était limite le plus long j'ai
mis après un an et demi à le penser et à
l'époque je travaillais dans des assauts
de la butte de protection de
l'environnement donc à l'époque j'étais
à tara océans c'est une asso voilà qui
parle beaucoup de l'océan du coup est en
fait petit à petit j'ai voulu vraiment
moi même faire un acte de
sensibilisation et je voulais le faire à
mama mama manière cd remportant mon
propre message est un monde détachant de
ski à aujourd'hui voilà c'est ça prouve
un truc j'y vois là c'est vrai qu'on on
est on est on est pas tendre avec tous
les groupes politiques d'ailleurs
vraiment mais c'est que l'écologie c'est
vrai que anne hidalgo fait beaucoup pour
l'écologie que c'est pas mytho non mais
c'est vraiment voilà c'est pas mitonné
génération est très con c'est exact non
mais si c'est important de dire oui tu
es mon sk8 des moments plus difficiles
que d'autres pendant cette course est ce
que vous avez eu des moments où vous
avez eu envie d'arrêter moi quand il a
pensé à tiger
il y en a toujours c'était pas mon
premier défi il ya quatre ans avant
j'avais traversé la manche à la nage
aussi ah oui et voilà donc j'ai j'avais
l'habitude quand même de ces phases
mental il ya toujours des hauts des bas
et puis en fait c'est sale aventure
c'est de savoir continuer quand on est
dans un bas est de savoir aussi profiter
des eaux voilà j'ai bien traverser une
manche soit par une balle
je vais avancer sont trouvés non merci
tu ne ferais pas d'émission
voilages et le crawl et on sait que la
scène c'est très sale comment vous avez
fait parce que vous avez la bouche
ouverte j'imagine que vous avez fermé à
l'est de los donc est-ce que vous avez
pris un traitement particulier ben alors
non en fait je me suis surtout préparer
sur le plan de la nutrition avant j'ai
passé vraiment un an et demi a même
essayé de comprendre quelles sont les
maladies dans la seine etc c'est sûr que
c'est pas anodin aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça qu'on peut pas aller se baigner dans
la seine mais honnêtement voilà
cinquante jours dans la scène jeune âge
et six sept huit heures par jour et j'ai
rien eu aucun mal de ventre aucun bouton
rien de rien et on se faisait des haltes
et tout s'est passé mais en fait je
dormais c'est pour ça que envoie jeu
patient voit sur les images mais j'avais
un kayak derrière moi et je bivouaquer
en bord de seine donc donc même dans
paris voilà j'ai bivouaquer face face à
notre dame l'année ce qui était bon
c'est incroyable c'est
très fier
d'avoir vraiment
c'est incroyable
il ya une rumeur qui dit qu'il est prévu
certainement de faire sur les grands
boulevards un couloir de natation pour
vous est ce que c'est que c'est en
projet ou est-ce que ça va se faire on
part quand je veux bien mais il va voir
des gars comme un songe à y aller plus
vite il
votre mère a été fier de vous bah ouais
bien sûr monsieur ouais elle était très
contente balma soutenu comme une mère
mais bon je n'en mets et je le dis et
anne hidalgo j'ai rencontré une fois
elle est très sympathique non mais chose
c'est vraiment un amour de femme après
on la vanne parce que quand je n'arrive
pas à les voir mes parents le samedi
après midi
voilà la fête avec toi
mais c'est vrai qu'en tout cas je trouve
que c'est sinon
jean germain venir nous voir ce soir
parce que franchement ça m'a fait
plaisir ça m'a touché et je trouve que
c'est c'est
sabine cas ce serait qu'on l'applaudisse
réformer
[Applaudissements]